[Música]
más
y
[Música]
por fin cuatro menos cuarto tenía que
estar hoy está llegando siempre es lo
mismo nosotros
estoy segura de que todos han vivido
algo parecido a esto alguna vez
momentos en los que tanta emocionalidad
es controladas hace que se rompan
vínculos de años
momentos en los que quizás pensamos que
bueno sería contar con recursos para
gestionar nuestra emocionalidad
para liderar nuestras vidas hacia donde
queramos partir
y marianos y yo somos amigos desde hace
unos 11
dentro de este tiempo y hemos aprendido
a superar situaciones parecidas a ésta y
lo hemos hecho gracias a que lo hemos
gestionado gracias a una serie de
recursos que nosotros hoy no queremos
compartir con ustedes
en mi caso particular el liderazgo lo
tome o lo tuve que vivir desde el punto
de vista de las ciencias que se conocen
como blandas yo me formé en derecho en
lingüística filosofía y bueno en este
transitar mi propio camino primero tuvo
que influir me a mí mismo para poder
liderar me y luego me ha tocado tener
que influir a otras personas para
liderar en diferentes contextos a mí me
tocó transitar por el camino del
liderazgo desde la llamada ciencias
duras
yo me formé como licenciada en sistemas
de información y durante mucho tiempo me
dediqué a acercar soluciones a personas
y empresas utilizando como herramientas
las computadoras la forma
en esos años de trabajo compartí con
muchas personas que pensaban diferente a
mí creían las soluciones de manera
diferente
entonces me pareció importante
incorporar recursos para liderar y ahí
fue donde descubrí que primero tenía que
liderar me para poder liderar equipos de
trabajo y en un punto de nuestras vidas
nosotros nos encontramos
nos dimos cuenta de que estábamos
caminando con un mismo
un camino bastante poco transitado un
camino que iba por el medio
un camino en donde lo blando y lo duro
se fusionan se complementan exacto un
camino del que sabemos cuándo se inició
y que también sabemos que ya no tiene
vuelta atrás
y si hablamos de liderazgo hablamos de
mucha bibliografía escrita al respecto
y en toda esa bibliografía aparecen
disciplinas como las neurociencias que
vienen arrojarlos a conceptos que tienen
que ver con el liderazgo si por ejemplo
yo les dijera que piensan
en el aroma del café de la mañana ese
recién preparado que nos gusta tomar a
todos
en el aroma del césped recién cortado se
le viene a la mente alguna imagen para
un recuerdo
y alguna emoción
hizo de asociar una situación externa a
un estado emocional interno tiene un
nombre para neurociencias y eso se llama
anclaje o memoria de destello
por diferentes razones de la vida a mí
me ha tocado tener qué
en diferentes países del mundo vivían en
países de centroamérica de europa de
asia así entré en contacto con
diferentes culturas
con religiones distintas a la mía etc y
así encontré en un libro de la india que
se llama ramayana que data de 5000 años
atrás un concepto que en palabras
sánscrito se dice
sam's cara y que se podría traducir como
surco en la memoria de una persona ese
concepto assange cara es exactamente el
mismo concepto que acabamos de
explicarle con maria luz de anclaje o
memoria de estrella hace cinco mil años
y eso ya estaba escrito y hacia dónde
vamos con todo esto que les estamos
contando bueno hacia el inicio del
camino del medio hacia empezar a liderar
nos
y resulta que para empezar a transitar
ese camino es bien importante decidir
llevar adelante procesos de
transformación y crecimiento personal
entre tantas cosas que estudiamos con
jose encontramos un modelo que
representa eso exactamente que nosotros
estábamos buscando
stephen hill gang un famosísimo
psicólogo norteamericano definió un
modelo en el que existen tres energías
inherentes a todos los seres humanos
tres energías que deberían estar en
equilibrio en todo buen líder
esas energías son la fuerza que tiene
que ver con la determinación con la
voluntad para llevar adelante nuestros
objetivos la compasión que tiene que ver
con la empatía con la capacidad de
construir y sostener vínculos sanos
el humor que tiene que ver con la
flexibilidad con la creatividad con la
capacidad de solucionar situaciones
difíciles de manera diferente
estas tres fuerzas deberían estar
siempre en equilibrio porque cuando la
fuerza se presenta sin compasión y sin
humor se convierte en despotismo
se convierte en agresión en violencia
cuando la compasión está sin fuerza y
sin humor es debilidad es sometimiento
y cuando el humor está sin la fuerza y
sin la compasión
hablamos de ironía de sí mismo de engaño
jarre interesante analizar estas tres
energías en las diferentes personas y
nosotros lo hemos hecho estudiamos la
biografía de muchos líderes de la
historia
pero nos encontramos con algo bastante
particular por ejemplo estudiamos la
biografía de este señor
al capones y nos dimos cuenta que en el
esas tres energías estaban bastante
equilibradas también él tenía fuerza
tenía motivación sabía dónde iba a tener
uno que tribune' claro también tenía
compasión porque sabía que solo no podía
era necesario trabajar en equipo y era
necesario generar en papilla y también
era bastante creativo para solucionar
los problemas que se le presentaban
ustedes saben que él usó una cadena de
lavanderías en chicago para lavar dinero
de ahí viene el concepto del lavado de
dinero pero precisamente este señor no
era el modelo de líder que nosotros
pretendíamos que la gente siguiera
entonces lo veíamos como una suerte de
mesa con tres patas tres patadas la
fuerza de la compasión y lomo pero le
faltaba algo a esa mesa le faltaba una
pata para generar el equilibrio
estudiamos mucho estudiamos mucho y nos
dimos cuenta que esa falta que faltaba
era la de la espiritualidad
pero escritor ya concebida como valores
y como principios pero no asociada a una
religión en particular
la espiritualidad esa que nos lleva a
hacer las cosas cotidianas que hacemos
pero una manera mucho más trascendente
el sentido de la trascendencia
y así entonces nos encontramos con otros
líderes
en donde si se dan las cuatro energías
se daban las cuatro patas de la mesa
como por ejemplo gandhi y albert hay dos
personas que sin duda dejaron huella en
la humanidad y si hablamos de
trascendencia y hablamos de
espiritualidad
hablamos de pasión de pasión por la vida
hablamos de ese espacio donde los
límites desaparecen los miedos ya no
están
hablamos de familia hablamos de trabajo
hablamos de amigos hablamos de alegría
hablamos de música y todo eso como un
jugado para que nuestros corazones
[Música]
e
y yo les pregunto y me pregunto cómo
hacemos las cosas de nuestra vida
por obligación o compasión esa pasión
que dicta desde la espiritualidad se
contagia
y permite que construyamos espacios más
humanos más felices pero que muchas
veces las ideas más interesantes más
originales se nos ocurren en los
momentos menos pensados y en los lugares
menos pensados ward les comentó una
anécdota personal un día entró de la
ducha de mi casa y estaba con el prefijo
neuro dándome vueltas por la cabeza
porque están pensando en palabras como
neuroeconomía neuromarketing vieron que
ahora todo es neuro no sea otro vano y
se me vino la mente esa idea y dije un
aura espiritual
es eso salir corriendo cielo computadora
de mi casa ingrese a la biblioteca más
grande del mundo es decir y escribe que
el concepto al liderazgo neuro
espiritual
saben cuál es el resultado de esa
búsqueda un enorme cero
por lo menos hasta ese momento a nadie
se le había ocurrido entonces lo que
hice fue haciendo notar mi profesión de
base de abogados los registre para que
nadie me roben algo por supuesto bueno
parece entonces yo estaba escribiendo
algunos papelitos en algunas servilletas
de algunos barrios donde frecuentaba
escribir algunas cosas y eso lo tenía
guardado en la caja de zapatos yo saqué
informático y con el tiempo me di cuenta
de que yo tenía una forma del libro
entonces un día golpea una casa de maría
luz la puerta y le dice tus manos tengo
esto corregido
y yo por supuesto lo corregí dio su
opinión y también él escribió el prólogo
esto se transformado en un libro sobre
esto podemos hablar muchísimas cosas
realmente muchísimo pero hoy nosotros
queremos compartir una definición con
ustedes
lideramos neuro espiritual es un meta
modelo transdisciplinario de influencia
y persuasión en donde convergen la
ciencia
sí bueno esta modelo significa que es un
modelo que trasciende otros modelos que
ya existan es transdisciplinario porque
toma elementos de diferentes disciplinas
de la programación de la lingüística del
coaching de la inteligencia emocional de
la ingeniería inversa y es de influencia
porque sirve para influir no a nosotros
mismos y para influir a otras personas
pero algo que es muy importante
la ética y los principios son el pilar
fundamental de este modelo es un modelo
eficiente porque utiliza muy pocos
recursos
y logra resultados realmente duraderos
en el tiempo sería como una forma de
arte japonesa que se llama kim sung y
les comento
quien su bien es una forma de arte que
permite unir con hilos de oro las
diferentes piezas de un jarrón que se ha
roto
para lograr una versión mejorada de
semilla
de la misma manera hidrógeno liderazgo
neuro espiritual permite lograr una
versión mejorada de nosotros mismos y de
nuestra relación con los demás liderazgo
neuro espiritual sería entonces los
hilos de oro
como aplicamos esto en nuestra vida
bueno haciendo de manera consciente las
cosas simples
aprendiendo a respirar
y siendo muy observadores y atentos a lo
que pasa con todas las emociones y nos
dicen a nuestro cuerpo los latidos del
corazón los gestos que acompañan a
palabras y acciones aprendiendo a
escuchar a escuchar 100% aquí y ahora
disponible para la persona que estoy
escuchando dejando de lado mis
pensamientos y mis prejuicios
aprendiendo a hablar desde mí desde lo
que yo necesito no desde lo que vos me
haces porque las personas no nos hacen
cosas las personas hacemos lo que
podemos en cada momento
recursos que tenemos disponible
aprendiendo a mirarnos de manera
consciente y saben que para eso nosotros
los seres humanos tenemos una ayuda
maravillosa saben ustedes que somos la
única especie que tiene tan grande hilo
blanco del ojo
y saben ustedes para qué
para nada que tenga que ver con la
visión lo blanco del ojo está allí para
que nosotros podamos encontrar
rápidamente la pupila de la otra persona
entablar un canal de comunicación
en definitiva se trata de aprender a
trabajar junto
en sintonía fluyendo corazón y razón
convirtiéndonos en seres sentipensante
parafraseando al gran eduardo galeano
dejando que corazón
cerebro vayan de la mano
los invitamos a vivir una experiencia en
donde hacemos conscientes lo simple
y ya no vamos a hacer
necesito para eso que confíen en mí y
que vayan haciendo lo que yo les voy a
sugerir puede ser dejen si pueden lo que
tienen en sus manos siéntense
cómodamente en las sillas
a poseen sus pies en el piso
si pueden pongan los pósitos separados
quedar a la altura de los hombros
despegue en un poquito su espalda de la
silla
muy bien pueden hacer esto con los ojos
cerrados o lo pueden hacer con los ojos
abiertos les aseguro que con los ojos
cerrados se vive de manera la gente
vamos a ser consciente nuestra
respiración
respiramos profundamente una vez
inhalamos
saltamos
y ahora que somos conscientes de nuestra
respiración
empecemos a escuchar los latidos de
nuestro corazón
nati llevando la sangre por todo nuestro
[Música]
y ahora que somos consiguen
y de los nativos
abrimos nuestros ojos
[Música]
y sonreír
porque las autorices mágicas
y hemos generado una emocionalidad
diferente de verdad
y eso lo hicimos
un poquito más de un
por eso nuestra invitación es a que
tomemos ese minuto de nuestras vidas
para agregar los
para navegar nuestra naturaleza hacia el
puerto al que queremos llegar
[Aplausos]